what's up this is cheeky recommends and
today we're talking about the sickest
leather jackets on the planet today
we're going to talk about some of our
favorite leather jacket style icons the
best leather jackets at every price
point and also how to style one leather
jacket three ways
[Music]
the best leather jackets at every price
point
there are a lot of leather jackets out
there in a huge range of price points
and that's not for no reason they're
different types of leather and different
qualities of leather I'm sure you guys
have looked at a tag and saw oh yeah
genuine leather this is the real thing
right I mean I think we all do that but
did you guys know that
that's not exactly the case when
something says genuine leather what do
you mean
I'm so glad you asked I'm like genuinely
curious
genuinely yeah that's right yeah so a
general rule of thumb is that the more
specific a tag can get about the type of
leather that's used that's probably a
better sign of quality and genuine
leather more often than not is an
amalgamation of
tiny scraps of leather that are
essentially like glued and bonded
together and so genuine leather is not
what you're you're picturing where they
like they take a full hide and they make
a jacket out of it exactly exactly yeah
when you're shopping for a leather
jacket there's just like so many options
available to you that it can be a little
confusing you might see some price tags
and think oh I can't afford a leather
jacket and we wanted to sort of break
this down by price point you know Gerald
took 500 ish and under I took like 500
to 1500 roughly and avadon will be
showing you some of the coolest leather
jackets you can get if your budget is
unlimited and so we just wanted to show
you that you can get a great leather
jacket you know no matter what your
budget is with some great quality to
look for too
so if I or you only had about 500 bucks
to spend you know it's not nothing but
leather once you get in the leather
jackets I wouldn't really go much lower
than that if you're looking for
something that's going to last you a
while at this price point there are two
jackets that I really like the first one
is from sephir a really cool Swedish
brand that a lot of us in the office
like a lot and generally speaking their
prices are pretty reasonable and their
Francis jacket is a great option it's
made out of faux leather which might
scare people away but that industry has
gotten a lot better and you're seeing
really convincing fake faux leather
options out there this one comes in a
Croc print if you have something that
has more of a finish or like fun print
to it that will kind of help hide any
imperfections that you might see from
other you know materials in this price
point if someone wanted to spend around
500 or less and get into real leather
territory what would you recommend there
well there are options at this price
point for real leather Beyond you know
above genuine leather and sort of like
hack I guess is to look for suede one of
my favorite options is from Banana
Republic yes the one at the mall
it's really handsome it's it's got a you
know classic sort of trucker jacket
style it's a little bit cropped which I
think goes well with high-waisted pants
or jeans it's a classic silhouette
gonna look great on everybody the suede
is really Supple give it a feel
wow that's smooth that's Sumptuous and
yeah you know you see movie stars where
suede truckers just like this one on the
red carpet all the time and I don't
think anyone would blink an eye you know
if they saw someone show up to a red
carpet Premiere wearing this exact
Banana Republic jacket yeah absolutely
young your job was slightly easier your
budget was 500 to 1500 did you find
anything good yeah absolutely you know
this is a great range to play with I
felt really lucky to get this assignment
because there are some amazing options
available to you some like real classic
leather jacket options so so my pick if
I you know only had around a thousand
dollars to spend on a leather jacket my
number one pick would be the shot
Perfecto because you know it's a legend
right in its own right it's an absolute
icon it's worn by Marlon Brando it was
worn by The Ramones worn by The Sex
Pistols this is like the leather jacket
you think of when you hear the words
leather jacket and so shot is an old
school New York brand it's almost 100
years old they still make all of their
jackets in America it's made of really
tough you know beautiful leather and you
know this classic biker Style is never
going to go out of style if you own this
type of leather jacket and a white
T-shirt and blue jeans and black boots
you've got an outfit that can take
yeah that is like a can't Misfit that
being said as great as this jacket looks
with a white tee and jeans there are so
many other ways you can wear it you know
like I think of a classic GQ cover with
David Beckham where he's wearing this
leather jacket pretty much with a crisp
white dress shirt and a black tie and he
looks incredible so that brings us to
avidon you had basically all the money
in the world
what did you find what did you pick at
your price point if you're spending that
much money on a leather jacket you can
kind of expect it to come with a certain
degree of quality right but what helps
to narrow down the search a little bit
is to look at brands that you know and
that have like some sort of pedigree in
that specific space the one I went with
as my topic is this leather blousing
from Celine which is kind of a different
silhouette than any of that we've talked
about yet it almost looks more like a
cropped trucker or uh a boxier button-up
shirt except it has a zip front and it's
made out of this really Sumptuous
slightly patterned leather I think if
you're going to spend an absolutely
ludicrous amount of money on a leather
jacket you'd be hard-pressed to find a
better option than this one
you get what you're paying for
essentially so it comes with the
designer pedigree and this really sick
precise silhouette that kind of hits
exactly where you want it on the waist
but essentially what all those dollars
are getting you is the leather which is
Top Notch right you know a lot of the
Allure of a jacket that expensive is
like just how good and cool you'll feel
yeah putting it on you know you can't
put a price on that confidence boost
apparently you can
so obviously with no budget there's a
ton of different options too strong
which is why this was so fun but the
other one that I would pick as one of
the best on the market right now is this
sort of Proto trucker jacket silhouette
from Saint Laurent it's made out of a
really Supple drum lambskin it feels
super Luxe
which makes sense because it costs like
over 6K so you wouldn't really expect
anything less and in fact I liked it so
much that we pulled a few strings put it
on gq's Tab and called in three versions
for each one of us to try on sweet just
to try on not to take home listen Gerald
if one goes missing I'm not going to be
making any phone calls but both of ours
can't go missing
one leather jacket styled three ways
so you know obviously we love the Saint
Laurent jacket it's beautiful it's
Exquisite but it's also just very simple
and we wanted to show how one great
leather jacket could fit into all three
of our wardrobes which I think we would
all agree are quite different like I
think a lot of times people get
intimidated by the idea of wearing a
leather jacket that you can really only
wear it one way or it's going to make
you look a certain way but I think what
we're hoping to prove in this segment is
that anyone can wear a leather jacket
and there's a million ways to style them
young like you said we each have very
different personal Styles so I'm curious
to see how we'll all wear it and make it
our own yeah absolutely
[Music]
dude walk us through this fit what's
going on here give me the breakdown we
picked this jacket for a few reasons one
is that it's actually not so crazy
there's not a lot of bells and whistles
like a Perfecto or you know it's not a
huge over-the-top you know trench coat
or something very simple it's very
elegant yeah it's pretty simple pretty
elegant uh it's sort of got an 80s vibe
to it but I think he might categorize
this as like uh maybe a a type of
aviator jacket albeit like a spin on it
I like that it's a little bit short
maybe like a trucker jacket I like where
the Shoulders hit and I mean really like
with any piece especially a leather
jacket you want to make sure that the
shoulders are right whether it's a suit
jacket a leather jacket whatever the
case might be it's like the one thing a
tailor really can't fix is the shoulders
and so as long as that fits like you
know you should be in pretty good shape
yeah absolutely how did you decide on
what you were going to pair with it I
guess my style you know it's you've
you've seen me it's not over the top
like I said before for the longest time
I felt like oh it's too cool for me I
can't like I can't touch that but
finding a jacket like this I sort of
leaned into the all black look I have a
vintage tee on and You Found Glory baby
you know Found Glory it runs over you my
first yeah my first bantee I still have
it I have some kind of moto esque boots
some vintage ones from Red Wings got
some texture to it which I really like
and these vintage black kind of slim-ish
pants so just sort of play into the all
black like brutish leather jacket feel
but not have it feel like Marlon Brando
or like the usual right you know icons
you might have in your hand yeah I think
you nailed it that's what's great about
it nice suits the jacket suits you young
you and I have a very different style uh
we've got the same jacket I am very
curious to see how you're gonna style it
let's find out cool
Young
looking great can you walk us through
your fit yeah in my mind there's like
nothing like a great leather jacket with
some thrashed Levi's and some Doc
Martens so I kept the lower half pretty
classic but my style tends to Trend a
little preppier a little dressier
sometimes top half I went like a shirt
and tie you know and this is like a cool
vintage long vent tie that I stole from
my dad sorry pops and just like a clean
white dress shirt which you can't really
go wrong with either and then just for
like you know 90s Samuel L Jackson Vibes
I went with the backwards Nike cap up
top I don't know I think it all kind of
comes together what do you guys think
yeah I think it's perfect yeah
proportionally looks really clean I mean
also I tend to default to just a good
pair of jeans because it's like it works
yeah it works with everything when you
can't think of what to wear pair of
jeans exactly leather jackets and jeans
is always a good look you know if it's
just like a great default if you happen
to have an amazing leather jacket and an
amazing pair of jeans you've got you
know the workings of an excellent
excellent outfit that you can lean on
and go back to over and over and over
again this is like maybe a little high
concept or a little bit of a weird Twist
on it but I you know I just kind of went
for it and so you get what you get
avadon look and fly tell us about your
fit thank you young I feel like this is
essentially an outfit that I wear a
variation of like a few days a week it's
just really easy to me mostly because
it's largely like dark tones and I think
there's kind of a rumpled Elegance to it
though maybe I'm giving myself a little
bit too much credit I wanted to lean
into like the leather jackets sort of a
rock star Heritage which explains the
very impractical scarf that's around my
neck right now not really doing too much
from a warmth perspective but it adds a
little bit of textural interest I'm
wearing dress trousers with a slight
sheen and a pretty crisp crease some
scuffed loafers from paraboot white
socks and this rumpled blue dress shirt
I feel like if I was getting dressed in
a rush and I kind of lost track of time
I would throw on all these sorts of
things and probably look somewhat decent
wherever I'm headed I mean this is a
conflict it looks like you're like
rushing to go get a drink at the Odeon
in like 1987. that's all I ever wanted
to hear y'all
and you look great you look again it's
very understated it's very simple it's
very you and it lets the beauty of this
epic Grail of a leather jacket sing
foreign
this was fun it's great to see you know
how differently we all styled the jacket
I feel pretty good in it you know like
it's like often awkward to like be
matching with people like showing up
wearing the same thing but we're not
really Spider-Man memeing here like we
actually really do very much look like
ourselves and look different even though
it's the same jacket I'm never really
thinking about it as like a oh fall Jack
or a winter jacket it's just kind of
kind of like a pair of jeans honestly
right you'd wear that all the time yeah
leather jackets they're Evergreen
leather jacket icons
[Music]
so obviously there's a giant Pantheon of
legendary style icons who have worn
leather jackets Brando and the Wild Ones
Travolta and grease Tom Cruise and Top
Gun Lawrence Fishburne and the Matrix
all of these incredibly stylish dudes
we've thought about and idolized over
the years so we wanted to take a little
different swerve on that right we wanted
to do our personal leather jacket Gods
avanon who is your style icon the one
one Undisputed leather jacket King my
guy Ralph Lauren pulls off a leather
jacket better than almost anyone else
like he's got a crazy collection right
he has like the western style cowboy
friend suede jackets he's got the
classic Moto jackets the Brando esque
Easy Rider and he makes it all look so
cool because he wears it with like
battered blue jeans and cowboy boots and
all the other Hallmarks of traditional
American style he's the goat it's pretty
easy to look cool in leather jackets
when you own like a billion dollar
clothing Empire but what if what if you
were the kind of guy that only owned one
leather jacket and you made that leather
jacket look so cool that it's always
associated with you and will forever go
down as one of the greatest leather
jackets on one of the greatest leather
jacket wearers of all time who who could
you possibly be talking I am talking
about Anthony Bourdain The Legend he
spent his whole life traveling the globe
right he was going to all these exotic
locations and he kept his wardrobe as a
result pretty simple it had to be able
to blend into a lot of different
environments in a lot of different
situations he favored things that he
could wear over and over again right
beat to Levi's 501s really cool
classic personal sunglasses and he had
this one leather blazer that he would
wear in all sorts of situations with all
sorts of different clothes and he always
always looked insanely cool in it you
know it was his go-to for a reason right
it just worked in so many different
situations and I think that's what you
want right I think you want to find that
one leather jacket that works for you
that can become a staple in your
wardrobe and associated with you and go
with you wherever you go in the world
so for me one of the best to ever do it
is Andre Leon Talley former editor at
large of Vogue and of course yes you
work in fashion you probably know a
thing or two about dressing I'll give
you that for sure but I love that Andre
doesn't just go for a jacket you might
you know usually associate with a
leather jacket there's not a jacket
there that's like subtle it's always
like a big long coat with like a Croc
embossed pattern on it or a big
shearling jacket like if you're gonna go
for it
why be subtle about it right and I think
what's great yeah about the three icons
that we just talked about is that they
are all so different and the jackets
they they preferred were so different
and it just goes to show right like no
matter who you are what your style is
there is a leather jacket out there for
you you're gonna you know just keep
looking because you will definitely find
it yeah absolutely I think they were all
very compelling arguments yeah right you
should just let us know in the comments
who was your favorite out of our right
yeah yeah and vote for me yeah thanks or
drop your own style icon below and tell
us that we're totally off base yeah that
works too
[Music]
hey thanks so much for hanging out with
us and watching today if you like any of
the jackets that we talked about they're
all in the description below all the
links are there don't forget to vote for
Ralph Lauren as her leather jacket style
icon in the comments or Andre leontali
or Anthony Bourdain just vote with your
conscience